- I'm talking about the
people with clean beds.
- What do you mean by clean people Jen?
What do you mean by clean people?
Who are you excluding in that?
Who's dirty?
The poor?
The poor Jen?
- [Jen] No!
- I rest my case.
- Showers, an invigorating
way to start the day,
or are they a smooth, relaxed
way to cap off your night?
I don't know, we're gonna
figure it out though.
Morning showers versus night showers.
It's debatable.
(uplifting music)
- I'm Kelsey, and I shower at night.
- And I showered this morning.
- I take showers in the morning
because I'm not a crazy person.
- And I take showers at night.
- And I'm for night showers.
- And I'm in favor of morning showers.
- I'm in support of morning showers.
- I'm here for the night shower.
(upbeat music)
- What's better in the morning
than just waking up
(sighing)
"I'm tired, let me hop in that shower,
"let me get fresh, let me
be alert, let me wake up."
- Morning showers wake
you up in the morning.
It's a great way to start your day
by getting clean and saying,
"Hey, ready for a new one."
- Have you heard of coffee?
It does the same exact thing.
- My opponent might say,
"Yes, well I can wake up
"with something like coffee, or drugs,"
but we don't need that.
- Did you just call me a drug addict?
- I sweat profusely when I sleep.
I'm a very sweaty man, as a result
I am disgusting in the morning,
and a shower very quickly
solves this problem.
- You're gonna go to
bed, you're gonna sweat,
you're gonna drool, no one
looks pretty when they sleep.
- I do, it's called "Sleeping
Beauty" have you read it?
It's a book.
- That was a fairy tale!
- Yeah, but it's also
the story of my life.
- Take a shower, you're
fresh, you're ready
for whatever the day has to throw at you.
you got a meeting, boom, fresh.
You're not like, "Oh, I'm all sweaty
"cause I was laying in bed all night."
- I don't get that, how
sweaty do you get at night?
- It depends.
- How hot is your room, it depends.
- Shower solves everything.
- You know what shower doesn't solve?
- [Man] What?
- Sexism.
- Look, I care about the American people.
I care about your emotional state.
You go through a long hard day,
it's rough, you're tired,
you have a cup of tea.
- You have a nice cup of tea.
- You have a hot cup of
tea, and then you get
in a nice hot shower.
- Going throughout the day, you get dirty.
We're lifting these heavy lights,
we're working on set, we get sweaty.
- All that pollution is on your skin.
It's been a hectic day, you're sad,
and so you want to go
and just wash it all off,
relax yourself.
- I also think that showering at night
is better for the environment.
Most people in the morning,
they take really hot
showers for a longer time
because they're tired
and they're tryin' to use it to wake up.
- I don't know.
A cold shower wakes you up.
- Cold showers wake you up.
Warm showers, they can relax you,
that's why hot tubs exist.
- Hot tubs are just like,
you just sit there and go like this.
Shower's just water just coming on you.
- You have a weird faucet.
- [Man] It's a great one.
- It does not come like this.
- [Man] It does.
- No, it's just nice like.
- As a woman, we're told that our value's
only based on physical appearance,
and so forcing me to wake up, you know,
an hour earlier so that I
shave my legs in the morning
cause men tell you that you
have to look a certain way.
- Why is men in quotation marks?
(laughing)
- Wouldn't it be luxurious if
could just roll out of bed,
and fuckin' put on a
T-shirt, and go to work.
Yeah, that would be nice,
but I got to fuckin' put
on my armor God dammit.
I gotta do all of this
shit to look this good
in a male driven society.
People gotta take me seriously.
(uplifting music)
- In conclusion, I wake up in the morning,
I take a shower, and I smell
good for the rest of the day.
- When you take a shower at night
you're not sleeping in your own sweat
and pollution all night, and it's better
for your skin, it's better for humanity.
- You're acting like I
take a dump in my bed.
- I don't know.
- I would say that I would
love to live in a world
where me and everybody else was capable
of taking a night shower,
but it's just not realistic.
- Ultimately, this debate is one
that's really hard to
apply to a macro level.
- Morning showers are best for men,
and if a woman would
want to take her shower
the night before, I get that.
- I agree, I'm proud of this Chris.
I think we learned something here today.
(uplifting music)
- Okay, are we having
a smell test right now?